back again
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
welcome back to your
favorite podcast
yes
what's up y'all and we back and we back
and we back it's birthday week
i'm here to tell you about my i took a
trip to san diego with rachel i did a
show loki outside
matt breif paul leah ian edwards
um so i'm gonna tell you about the trip
to san diego
uh by having my birthday uh why i shaved
um what else uh just some stuff that's
going on out there some movie reviews
uh but anyways
yes all right and we're back
all right we're back we're from work
we're fans solo
solo there's gonna be some bitching with
griffin we're going to open
up with some bitching with griffin
that's what i say you know cause i went
to san diego it was my birthday uh
matt rife asked me to do you know his
show they go
it's called low-key outside to do a
bunch of shows around la and trying to
expand other places anyway
so he asked me to do the show and i
thought oh you know what it's my
birthday
so this is actually kind of cool thing
so i'm gonna take rachel
you know we'll stay in a hotel spend a
couple days the 12th is my birthday
13th with the show that we came home you
know on the 14th
so it's like you know yeah let's have a
little fun time so
rachel likes staying at the beach okay
she likes staying at the beach
so i got i booked i went online
found a little like that's where the
venue was and i said hotels
hotels nearby and it was a pacific beach
in san diego so i was like all right let
me pick
you know a hotel i found one it was
reasonably priced they were 30
off you know it seemed like it was nice
the pictures they got me i got got
because on the website
it looks good you know what i mean the
room was well lit
it looked boutiquey okay so
we get we pull up immediately i didn't
realize pacific beach is like the
venice beach of san diego and if you
don't know what i mean by that it's like
venice beach is a weird spot it's just
hobo central
it's just a lot of weird a lot of young
people a lot of like
you know unsavory types that's that's
that beach but
not to the scale of it as venice beach
is but pacific beach is sort of
you know and i can tell even by the the
how the hotels look and
and the surrounding areas this is you
know you know and then one of the
selling points i'm not gonna say the
name of the hotel but one of the selling
points was like oh
we you know we're uh a walk away from
the best tacos in san diego
you know what i mean like that should
have been a key for me to be like oh
that's your selling point about the
hotel is some walking distance
taco truck like what anyways so you pull
up
there's no parking like they only have a
certain number of spots and it's coned
off
all right so you know i'm already like
hold on so when i go inside i go yo man
i'm not paying this amount of money to
have to park my car a mile away from the
hotel
it was already like just a little small
lobby one dude working at a computer
you know what i mean and i was like okay
this ain't a good start
he was like no don't worry i reserved
you a spot this is your spot right here
it was right in front of the thing
you use a cone right there's a cone you
have to move whatever and
and so i was already like okay we got a
spot 32
a night for the spot all right so that's
gonna be an extra 64
on top of the 200 whatever dollars it
was and that was supposedly a discount
okay so the um you know so all right i
told rachel she moves the car
i'm still a little bit like i don't like
where the car is parked
because the car's parked like the beach
is like right there and the walkway
you know it's like it just it don't look
safe and then the guy says oh well
the hotel closes at ten you know we his
office closes at ten
so now you're just on your own and on
top of that another red flag for me
is when when the hotel
the door to your room is outside
i'm out hear me i'm out okay i'm just
i'm boozy that way i don't want
the okay so there's like a little well
so i go up to
i go up and then you have to go this way
that way in the stairs everything's kind
of outside
and then i see like a one of the rooms
just open and some people just
looking out at us like they're just
looking hey you know and i'm thinking
okay these are the people are going to
steal all our [ __ ]
anyway get into the room
now i'm looking at the room and i'm like
hold up so
let's say like the room was a little ass
room
okay there was like
one window in the room okay this little
ass window and then you have the door
all right like a little it was upstairs
you know so like
we're facing this way and the beach is
like this
so the beach is over here right so
the door and the window is facing this
way and the beach is to the right so if
i'm facing the door
the beach is to the right and there's a
window that's the only window in the
damn thing
i look on my reservation i ask for ocean
view
i say ocean view right i want to oh
that's the whole reason why we coming
here it's ocd
by the way it was cold so it wasn't
gonna be like it was enjoyable i go down
and go hey man
look at my reservation ocean view oh oh
it's ocean view man
it's a window you know i go back into
the room
it's a little ass window like i'm on a
on a cruise ship
to see the beach you couldn't stand in
front of the window and look out like
this
you had to stand to like the right of
the window
in the corner near the like to the side
of the bed to see out the window and you
could sort of see the beach
that was the ocean view rachel comes in
and i know she ain't gonna like it
you know we're kind of looking at each
other and it's like
you know the toilet was too low to the
ground the bed was creaky
it's my birthday you know i'm gonna i i
don't want some creaky ass bed that
everybody know what we're doing because
i'm about you know i'm having some it's
birthday time you understand
i'm going hard on my birthday right
so i go down and talk to the guy no i
you know
rachel also she went up to the room
and i went down to like talk to him
about the ocean view rachel hits me with
a text talking about
she goes disgusting the bed is wet like
there was
the bed was damp i'm out
i go down to the guy and i go hey man
um it's my birthday so
i can't do this so can you like
refund me and to the guy's credit he was
cool
he gave me all the money back and we
bounced i went on my app
because i travel all the time so i'm on
i got all these rewards programs
went on a marriott got a room like this
it was way cheaper way nicer
we went to a nice restaurant right next
to the um
hotel larsen's shout out to them larson
san diego
you know they they had the balcony of
the the outdoor patio open but it was
still
covered so it was like really you know
you like you did they helped
it was a normal spot that they normally
have even when the world was normal
so you know we went eight had
so it was just but i just hate i got got
you know you look on somebody's website
right
the website of the hotel and the way
they got it set up you would have
thought
this was like a four-star like you know
really nice little like i say a little
boutique hotel right on the beach
they got amenities and all this kind of
stuff man this was just a
days in you know
on the beach like you get that term
beach
you hear beach and then you think oh
it's on the beach
so that means this is gonna be great now
man
beach just fools you into thinking that
you're going to settle for all that
other stuff
and and this looks like a young person's
thing you could tell i could tell that
young people this is their kind of room
they go oh that's great we're right on
the beach and we can walk up and down we
do all this stuff
not me i'm too old for that now i'm a
creature of comfort
all right i'm a creature of comfort so
this trip didn't start off good
but but like i say we got to the hotel
and everything was working out so it was
great
and by the way thanks for being here
riffing with griffin and make sure you
um
if you uh subscribe you know all that
stuff and
you know watch me game on air griffin
gaming
on twitch which i do every single day
all right so before i left for the
birthday adventure
you know i got i'm clean-shaven
well i'm not necessarily clean-shaven
now because it was like three days but
i'm sort of clean-shaven and the reason
is
because i got i had a great i had a big
audition had this great audition i felt
i
just feel like i'm back in the business
i ain't gonna really talk about it much
because i don't know what's gonna happen
actually today monday when this comes
out i'm probably gonna get the word
if i actually booked this or not so the
next time you hear from me
i'm either gonna be super happy or i'm
gonna be like ah man i was disappointed
but you move on to the next it's just
how it works
but i just been the reason why
you know and so they wanted me to be
clean [ __ ] they said you know can he
clean
shave so we can just see what that looks
like and i was like fine so we'll find
out it's a great role
it's a great part you know so i'm not
gonna talk much about that
but the reason i'm even thinking about
this is like
you know this is the anniversary of the
world going crazy you know
march 12th last year 2020 i was in
tennessee at uh at the
chattanooga at the comedy catch in
tennessee and it was already like in the
air people were talking about like we
don't know what's gonna happen
what's going on it was like really leery
the nba just canceled the game on march
11th
and then it was like i'm flying out for
my birthday to do the shows it was like
a thursday friday saturday you know
so once we heard the nba shut down the
thing it was like well people are still
going out and doing their shows
and then you know it was like march 12th
everybody's cancelling shows
it's time to go this particular club
didn't so i finished the weekend
and then i went home and then i was home
for
a year basically almost a year you know
so it's just the anniversary of that and
like look where we are
man you know look look where we are now
like today
driving back home from san diego well
when i the day that i filmed this which
is what's sunday you know
i do i do it on sunday um you know we
stopped at a restaurant
and we sat inside uh because they said
you know
monday march 15th their
restaurants are open again at a certain
capacity so
i feel like we're doing okay you know i
mean i don't know if we're doing okay or
not i i still honestly don't understand
the numbers i don't know what's going on
people think they understand what's
going on a lot of people like
how people talk about covet it really
annoys me
you know it's like most of you are
ignorant you like most of you
most of you that not not all of you i'm
saying the ones that
hit me up with their attitude the way
they hit me up
i know that they actually don't have
real solid information they're not
scientists they're not doctors
it's just people that they they read
some headline or they read something and
they think they know what they're
talking about
i freely admit i don't know anything i
don't know about this i'm just giving
you my
two cents about what i think based off
the things that you do know right
but i'm not attacking anybody about it
the way they attack me but look
man look at like all these things that
are coming out now we've been dealing
with this for a year
you know a year right so i saw this
thing where it was like
85 of the people that have died 85
percent in the united states
are over the age of 65. that [ __ ] was
mind-blowing to me
mind-blowing because it says to me that
we didn't handle
any of this right we don't take care of
the elderly in our country we weren't
looking after the people 65 and over
all this stuff about shutting everything
down and the way we did it it did
nothing
if those are the majority of people that
died
we should have been taking care of those
people more some of you don't care
because
you know if you're young you're in your
early 20s late
20s your parents might be 40s 50s so
even for you it don't mean nothing but
for my generation
where our parents are 70s 80s 90s just a
big deal man
and it's just a shame to me that like
when you see a stat like that
you know they now know more so they're
coming out like
you know so the elderly 65 and up
killed off people with pre-existing
conditions
and obesity is a big one and of course
nobody wants to talk about that nobody
wants to talk about it
i was on top of that [ __ ] immediately
because i was like whoa
i gotta take care of myself for two
reasons one my mom has dementia
and i need to think about is that
hereditary you know is it is it genetic
is it
am i pre pre exposed to getting that or
what can i do to stop that
and it's just being healthier so i had
to lose weight
work on my inflammation work on b12
vitamin d and all these things
and i have been really trying to take
care of myself i'm down 40 pounds of
body fat
especially in in in this area alone you
know what i mean
so i i
i was like to me i was like okay being
healthier
you probably will be able to overcome
this thing
you know what i mean it's just
i don't know what to say so now we're at
this point now where
we'll never know because now so many
people that were gonna die
or could die from it have died now
the rest of the people that are left are
now taking the vaccine
so now we got the people who are most uh
susceptible to
getting sick are now vaccinated
for the most part um and then so now
we're here so we don't even know
you know we don't you know we're going
to look him back and be like well why
did we shut down the way we did
and i'm not saying we shouldn't have
shut down i'm not saying we shouldn't be
taking precautions i'm not saying that
just because if you're young
then we just go willy-nilly no i think
to all the things that we did in terms
of wearing mass and social distancing
and
and capping the capacity of places and
all that stuff that that kind of stuff
we could have done
but i do not think that we the after
three or four months being into it that
we should have ruined everyone's lives
the way we did
ruined financially ruined people's lives
i think it should have been handled a
lot better and we dropped the ball and
we'll never know
because now they're just going to be
like oh we're opening up texas is like
yeah we're open up 100
no restrictions and then other states
are going to do that
and now we're going to sit here and be
like well is did we do this right
did we handle this situation correctly
oh no man i don't know
you know what i mean i don't know and
again i'm not saying
that you know we all i'm saying is the
way we did it
to me looks as if it was not done the
right way
and if some professional wants to come
out and say to me like well this is the
best thing we could have done
then okay fine but i don't think so you
know what i mean
until i get some solid information to me
it just looks like
you know we just weren't together as a
nation we weren't the leadership
you know they weren't planning this out
properly they weren't
being like hey let's look after the
elderly and
how like what do we have to do to make
sure the people that are
most susceptible to this are going to be
safe
and we just didn't do it because look
look at all the people that died
it's crazy
anyways i don't want to i'm it's just it
just made me think about it like it's
like a year and where are we now
because that's really what i'm trying to
think about it's like where are we
now look at all the stuff that has
happened in a year
you know like the comedy store like all
the different employees
who are now gone all the different
comics who are going away
all the things with allegations with
brian and chris
and you know it's like all that so you
know they're not gonna be back there and
it's like
rogan's gone and like it's like all of
these things that happened in 2020 was
just like
terrible you know so here we are
you know a year later and it's like
where are we you know
i mean for me how have i been affected
yes i mean one i feel like i'm trying to
get healthier i'm in a great
relationship
that was strengthened by the time we
spent together um
i'm engaged i'm moved to a better place
and just make i just feel like i i'm
trying to improve my life and make my
life happier
and share it with someone who i care
deeply for
so i try i feel like as i look back on
it i made the best of the situation
because i had the means to do that but
not everybody's in that situation and i
feel for you but i'm just talking about
for me
how i tried to like see the silver
lining in all of this
i mean we all should do that i think you
should all look at your lives and be
like am i better
how am i am i better or worse and there
are some people who obviously
just financially there's nothing you
could do but is there any silver lining
i mean because for me i'm just looking
at my life differently now like before i
was just all about comedy all the time
you know i'm getting my notebook and i'm
going to the lab factory the comedy
store and i got to go every night i'm
taking on as many shows as i can i'm
going to do this i'm going to do that i
want to stay relevant i want to stay on
there i want to make sure that you know
i'm running this rat race
and i feel like now that i wouldn't do
it the same
easy to say now because nothing's going
on but i really feel like
i have a much more appreciation for
being at home
being with my lady and enjoying that
enjoying my place you know sitting down
and watching some shows that i like to
watch
you know what i mean watching movies
that i like to watch you know you know
what i mean uh
and just like having dinner with her
just laying in bed with her and just
you know like you know and then
realizing like how can i monetize my
life in other ways
you know and that's why i did like when
i started doing the gaming error griffin
gaming on twitch and youtube
you know i thought oh here's other ways
i could do it and so then like i just
was struggling with who
am i as a person who am i am i still a
comic am i still an entertainer
like what is my life and then like cut
to now
you know i started to get auditions
again so i went on some few auditions
and then i got this really
great audition and i've gone through all
the steps and process where i'm like
right after like i'm right there it's
like me and a couple people and it'll be
like one of those life-changing jobs and
so
you know put out your energy that i
actually
you know i book it but even if i don't
um i
i know i i gave it my best and i feel
thrilled that i'm like
a part of the game still you know
even after everything that happened i'm
still a part of it and it makes me feel
good for the future regardless of what
happens so
it's just uh you know interesting
interesting year
you know and i think we should really
look back on the year and just
we know the bad stuff you know what i
mean and and i
my condolences go out to everyone that
lost someone close to them
um but even in that
take some time to hey
what did i learn about myself
and is my is my life
where is my life now and could it you
know what can i do to make it better
you know so that's what i say about that
but um yeah so i had this show in san
diego and it was great
you know low-key outside shout out to
them um and it was fun
you know i've been doing a lot of jokes
actually about rachel
you know like through the pandemic and
and this is the first time
in a year that she's with me at a show
and watching me do the jokes and so i
just love seeing her face
because she's like oh my god it's so
romantic that you're doing jokes about
me but it's like
i love doing the jokes because then i
look out at the crowd and i see other
couples and they're like oh the guys are
like that's you
and the girls are like oh my god i
totally relate so
that was fun that process was fun and
then like just hanging out in san diego
um you know with the other comics was
great
so like i said hopefully hopefully you
know they're talking about by july
that the world we're just going to be
back to normal you know
and i'm sure back to normal with these
other things like
this you know people hopefully will
still wear masks and you know be
socially distant and
you know being healthier and taking care
of themselves but you know you look at
some of these numbers man they're
talking about how teen suicide is up
alcoholism is up
uh drug use is up um domestic violence
is up it's like
all these things that have been affected
by this choice we made to shut down in
the way that we did
and how we kept it going with without
really any leadership without any like
guidance without any like plan it's felt
like you know
so hopefully we can like on the road and
heal the nation you know as best we can
so
i look forward to that but in the
meantime
i feel like this is the whole bitching
with griffin uh episode but
so they had this i want to talk about
some stuff so the one of the things i
want to talk about is that
that basketball player from the miami
heat he streams
he plays call of duty he has a twitch
channel i don't think he has a twitch
channel anymore
but uh his name is myers
leonard i believe is his name
um myers leonard uh
my place with miami heat so he was
apparently playing call of duty
and i know how it is like you playing
call of duty
man something about war zone call of
duty man you have your highest highs
your lowest lows
of emotions and it just you have this
just extreme anger and extreme happiness
in that game
so he flies off the handle something
happens
and he uses a racial slur in
the process and he uses the
an anti-semitic racial slur so
then he had this whole thing about like
oh i didn't know what it meant and all
this kind of stuff
i don't know man i don't know this dude
ain't gonna speak for him
all right but i will say this i know how
it is to be that angry when you're
playing call of duty and you say things
and i'm not excusing what he said at all
i'm saying you say things
but you say things that you know like
whatever that thing is that you normally
say
now here's what i'll say there's a lot
of racial slurs and things that
like are they retired or not are they
close like the n-word for instance
not retired will never be retired people
want it to be retired but it won't be
it's hard to retire a word that has been
reappropriated
by black people i use it you know i have
my friends
you know it's like it's been taken back
but because of that
it makes other people feel like well if
you're saying i'll say and so there's
always this
up and down about it there's always this
like
you know there's this sort of oh [ __ ] my
chair just went down did you guys see
that
[Laughter]
this chair is broken but anyways there's
always like a
there's always like a feeling about it
there's always like so it's one of those
things that's like it's still present
it's in rap music
it's in movies it's it's you know
there's it's that's a word that
is still around whether it should be or
not i don't know
i i you know you know what i mean i
don't actually if i'm just being honest
i don't know how i feel about it
you know you talk to some people who
will be like this is a terrible word it
has a terrible history which it should
be removed
then there's other people who are like
you know listen we've
we've taken the power away from it and
it's just a word and you know you
shouldn't let
it be so important you know you have
both sides of that argument you have
other people who are like nah only black
people should say it
no one else should say it but that makes
people like if anybody can say it
if one person can say it that means
anybody can say it that's how people
feel
i don't necessarily agree with it but
that's how people feel
it's like i was i directed my buddies i
directed a buddy of mine vinnie o'shanna
he has this uh uh
he he wrote a sketch he wrote you know a
sketch that he wants to pitch
anyways i i said hey let me direct it so
i directed it but one of the lines
is a black actor is saying the n word
in a context of the sentence you know so
you know as we're sitting around
ready to go and then one of the writers
who's a white guy
you know he just says it he said oh
we're gonna do the line such and such n
word you know
and he said it a couple times and so i
had to cut in and say hey hey
there's actually no reason for anybody
but the actor
who's going to say this to say this
moving forward there's no need to say
that out loud anymore so let's not say
that out loud anymore
you know because it's just there's no
there's no justification for it
you know let's not make a justification
for it let's just move on from it that's
just how i felt at the time
you know so but anyways the reason why
i'm bringing this up in terms of for
miles leonard
myers leonard whatever the [ __ ] his name
is is okay so
you have the n word it's still around
okay the other word i feel like is like
closer to retirement like really
you know being shamed is you know
the homosexual when you use the f word
let's say you know
rhymes with maggot you know what i mean
so it's like that's one of those that
like
people were saying it and they were
trying to justify it by like oh i don't
really mean that
you know uh it was like you know like
like [ __ ] is one of those words that
wasn't a bad word
but was turned into a bad word even
though that's a word that's an english
language word when something is [ __ ]
uh you don't necessarily mean like
somebody's dumb or stupid they're just
you know
there's an actual term for it you know
but that was taken and used in a
derogatory way
so now that was like oh we got to get
rid of that one [ __ ] another one that
you know you can't say that
you know you can't say it in a context
you know but i'm saying it out loud
because it's like that's a word that's
not
and how people used it they turned it
into a derogatory term
but the f word the n word uh but
the effort i feel like is
is like in retirement because there's no
there's no like gay rappers who are like
we reappropriated this and you know it's
just one of those words we go
hey we don't want to say this anymore
we're moving on okay
now that being said
that's how i feel about the anti-semitic
uh
k you know k word or i don't even know
how does it start with a k
yeah but that's he used my thing is this
that's been retired like there's
if you're saying that you
it just comes across like you know
exactly what it means
if you're still saying that it's so
harsh because it's been
taken away for so long i don't
my girlfriend's jewish my fiance's
jewish you know i have jewish friends
i i don't that's not even the one that
even comes to mind to me
with my comic friends even if we're just
joking around
you know because when comics joke around
they say some really terrible [ __ ] to
each other sometimes
it's not for it's not for you you know
it's not for you to even understand i
actually don't care what you think about
it
you know my friends and i when we say
things that's that's like locker room
talk you know
but when the locker room talk gets out
or somebody hears you saying the locker
room talk
at that point you have to step in a bit
hey i'm sorry that you heard that i'm
sorry
you know whatever that's what sucks when
that kind of stuff gets out because now
you're put in this position but anyways
that's one of those words i've never
said to
anyone you know even when i'm making fun
of my jewish friends
who might even use the n-word in jest in
private you know what i mean like but
that particular word
so i don't understand so you so it lends
itself to for you to think like damn
dude do you just not like
do you really not like jewish people or
like are you really anti-semitic in
a little bit or are you just there's
some kind of were you raised this way or
like you know
do your pain because we get that [ __ ]
from our parents when our parents like
you know
our parents are the ones that ingrain
racism towards certain people because of
their experience you know that that's
why racism is generational
you know what i mean it's like if your
grandfather was racist you know
you know maybe your father was trying
not to be racist but he learned some
racism from your father and so now
hey maybe you got a little bit but
you're trying to fight it and we have to
weed it out generation over generation
over generation
you can look at sports as a way of
seeing how it goes away it's like was
basketball was all white and then they
had black players and then now
basketball is mostly black and then you
have
you know the white coaches now there's
black coaches now you have black gm's
and now
but you know now we have one black owner
and so it's like
generation it takes a long time to weed
out that those
feelings and i think you know it's the
same thing with racism but so
i don't know man i just i feel for the
guy
you know i i genuinely feel like he
realized he made a mistake
for a lot of reasons even if he even if
he realized like oh man
this is a this is a culture of cancel
you know i mean this is the cancer
culture oversensitive
overreacting society that we live in
right now
that the mob like doesn't want to
actually communicate
and deal with things and use shame as a
way of being like
hey you know let's let's do better no no
they just want to like
remove people they want to erase people
you know they want to erase them and
remove themselves
from society that's how this culture and
society wants
is is so dangerous it's actually really
terrible
so i like that a few people have reached
out to the guy like julian ellen
edelman the football player from the the
ex football player from the patriots i'm
not sure if he's still there or not
but anyways i don't know i'm sure where
he plays but he wrote this really nice
op-ed piece like a real like a
like a letter to miles leonard saying
like hey man you know
reach out to me and i'll tell you why
this is hateful i'll tell you why it's
hurtful to say it
and how like you know even when you
think you don't understand what it means
and saying it
even that could be dangerous because it
just you know it it was really nicely
done
and that's the way you should it should
be dealt with you know but this guy you
know he's got the 50 000
fine he was away from the team for a
week now he's on the trade block it's
like a lot of like stuff going on with
this guy that you know
he made him he made a mistake you know
the dude made a mistake uh
so you know i i don't condone
that you know because i play with people
on my even on my stream
you know one of my friends that plays
with me he you know he said some things
a couple times and i had to say to him
hey man
you know what you got to be careful what
you say like let's
tone down on certain racial slurs and
things like that you just
you know not even tone down like don't
say them because you know you don't get
me thrown off twitch
you know even though i know you don't i
underst
it's like i understand and you should
also understand why
we shouldn't say these things so you
know what i mean it's it's tough
you know it's tough so it's like you
have these certain words that
people that we you know we want to
retire from society but you know
i i don't know i i don't know where i
stand on it sometimes i feel like why do
we give
words like this so much power when it
really has to do with like the intent
behind it
like you know it's like do you think
taking away a word is gonna take away
someone's
hate in their heart you know they just
that's how
that's how you make a word like [ __ ]
negative because
this is the word we've taken and now
we're gonna make it negative
you know so if you take away the k word
or the n word then they'll say well
we're going to say this
instead because it's the intent behind
it right that's how i feel about it i
don't know how you feel about it you
could tell me in the comments you know
because i'm sure there's going to be
plenty of people who are going to be
like you know you need to understand
what these words mean and where it comes
from and why it's hateful it's like i
get you
like i'm not i'm on your side okay so
don't don't come at me like you think
you understand
what i'm saying or how i feel you know i
get i'm on your side
i get why uh words have power and they
do
words have power um it's just how we
handle and how we deal with people
when these kind of things happen is my
issue you know so
hopefully hopefully the guy learned a
lesson
you know and hopefully this is like a
way for other people to learn from his
mistake
and be like yo like you know people in
entertainment and streamers and people
would be like
ooh let me watch what i say because
words have power and
it could hurt people's feelings whether
you feel like the word is
you know you're right to say whatever
you want or freedom of speech and all
that kind of nonsense
the point is you're an entertainer
you're doing
it's for entertainment and you want to
make sure that you're not
making people feel bad you know it's
it's tough
and that's that's and that's weird
coming from a stand-up comedian right
because
it's hard to be that's the line we have
to like
the line we cross and i've talked about
this before
but you know it's just basically there's
always going to be a butt
of the joke and sometimes the butt gets
slapped
you know sometimes it's a hard slap on a
butt
sometimes you know sometimes it's like
oh okay people like oh i like that are
they oh i don't like that
so but it's all about the intent
like i don't have ill intent
with my jokes but i am going to talk
about
everyone everyone's going to get it
white black whoever gay straight
transgender conservative liberal
i like to go at everyone the same
and i feel like when we're talking about
comedy
don't assume ill intent up top
and maybe you'll be able to just be like
oh okay
i've talked about this on other podcasts
it's like taylor swift man
you know she's watching jeannie and
george you know
which my girl brianna howard howie is
the star
she was on dine up here she's been on my
podcast she's a good friend
she's the star of that show it's a great
show it's funny it's dark
and they make a joke about taylor swift
you know they say oh you go through more
men than taylor swift
so i'm sure taylor swift was at home
watching this and then she got mad and
then she went to twitter
and stuck the mob on everybody
stuck the mob on them you know i thought
it was irresponsible
thought it was irresponsible and
dangerous like you are
such a big celebrity you have 100
million followers for you to attack this
these people it's like you know you know
how how toxic
it would get you know how dangerous it
would get you know what i mean and by
the way
i thought haiti was haters were gonna
hate i thought haters were gonna hate so
maybe shake that [ __ ] off
you know what i mean shake it off maybe
i don't know
shake it off taylor should we just you
know what i'm saying
shake it off shake it because haters go
hey hey hey
remember all that okay and these aren't
even really haters
it's actually a compliment to you
because
you're so big you know what i mean
it's um when people make fun of you like
that on such a scale
and a show like that it's really like a
hey we like you
so we're making you a part of the comedy
but shake it off girl
shake it off right
maybe all right what's up y'all
here to talk to you about betterhelp.com
better help are you depressed you know
the you know the world's been crazy for
a year right now and it has
a long lasting effect you know suicide's
up
drinking's up and all these things and
if you need some help
you need some help from a licensed
professional that's what i want you to
go to right now is
betterhelp.com that's
h-e-l-p-betterhelp.com
slash griffin get 20 off betterhelp.com
look join millions of people who have
taken charge of their mental health
you know you're not you're gonna have to
go to some crazy waiting room and you
know just feel uncomfortable
it's from the privacy of your own home
you know you set up an appointment you
will be contacted within 48 hours
and they have like i said this isn't
self-help this is
therapy this is a therapist who's going
to help you
organize your thoughts figure out where
the pain is coming from
because they they can recognize patterns
and they will help you it's not going to
solve your problem but it's going to
help you maybe
understand so i really appreciate having
this sponsor
betterhelp.com so make sure you check
that out
go to betterhelp.com griffin for a 10
off and you know take charge
of your mental health and start feeling
better today
let's get back to the show
so i was it's funny i was going to talk
about let me do a movie review now
um i was going to talk about this and
then i saw rogan talk about it so you
know when rogan talks about it it means
like
not no one else can talk about it
[Laughter]
but i do want to talk about it um
it's called i care a lot i saw on
netflix spoiler
alert okay spoiler if you want to watch
this movie
skip ahead okay to the next movie i talk
about
which would be bliss on amazon but
so it stars rosamund pike
who's great like she's such a phenomenal
actress
but spoiler alert so the movie's about
she's a con artist
you know she uh her khan is
a caretaker for elderly people and she
ends up you know robbing the elderly
people
puts them in a home takes all their
money sells all their property for money
and while the and then she and so the
doctors in on it the elderly home is in
on it
and so you know this is how the movie
opens up you see her she's just a snake
movie opens up with a guy who's like he
can't see his mom and this
you know you know what i mean they go to
court and he's like
cursing at her outside the courtroom and
you really see how she's a monster
like there isn't one redeeming
redeemable person
in this movie like everybody's terrible
okay and this is what i liked about it
because it made me feel something the
whole movie
because the whole movie you know you
know it's like especially in this day
and age of like where it's like me too
and feminism and like you know female
power and female empowerment right
so you had this movie where the female
lead you know so you so like do you want
her to win
that's the thing when you watch movies
now it's like all right all right here's
the female character
is she is she the star she the hero do
you want her to win well this [ __ ]
ain't a hero she's terrible
she's literally she's like a really
awful person
right and you feel that she's an awful
person in the whole movie
and then comes peter dinklage okay so
anyway she
you know the the star she um
[Music]
ends up you know finding
an elderly woman who they who you think
doesn't have a family you know and so
she's easy pickets and a woman's rich
so that you know so the doctor the the
shady doctor
signs you know saying that this woman
has mental issues and so
we need this caretaker to come in and
take care of her so they come and they
get her
it's really sad you know what i mean
because the whole time i'm thinking
about my parents i'm thinking about my
mom cuz somebody do this to my mom you
know what i mean
so they come and they get her they take
her you know they take her to a thing
and so then
later they've all they've sold all her
stuff they're painting her house because
this woman's put away in a thing they
won't let her
call anyone right and so then a guy
comes to the house looking for her he's
like yeah i'm here to pick up mrs
so-and-so
and then so she's not there the houses
move so he goes to peter dinklage who
plays this like
russian mobster he's like an ex
he faked his own death or something and
now he's like living in exile but he's
like
this like peter dinglish is
a he's a badass man just a phenomenal
actor and i believe him
you know even though it's like wow
you're like 117 pound little dude
like you're not you know you're not like
in real life you're not really
intimidating probably
right you know i mean i shouldn't even
say that but come on
like i'm six three i don't care if you
if you're less than five foot and weigh
100 pounds i'm beating your ass
okay let's just be real
but you know in a movie he just he's so
believable
so he plays this bad guy and this is
actually his mother
who's been taken away so now you have
this battle of will between peter
dinklage and her
and i won't tell you everything that
happens i'll try not to spell everything
but you know it is what it is the
spoiler alert you know so they have this
battle and that's what the battle
becomes between like him wanting to get
his mom
and her just wanting to win wanting to
have
money and power and influence and that's
why she's doing all this you know
so the whole movie goes on and you're
just like i'm like god everybody's awful
and then okay this is the major spoiler
part right now so if you've
thought you've stayed stuck around you
know what i mean this is part you might
want to
move forward too because
you think she wins and i'm watching this
movie man
and at the end and i'm thinking i'm
really shaking my head i'm like i can't
believe they're doing this
you know i'm like i can't believe
that and i was going in my head about
like oh i
oh so you know because it's a female
lead oh she's gotta you know win
and you know i was just going into this
hole in my stupid head about you know
and then bow something happens and
you're like and i thought oh
it it fixed it for me i was like
thank you and then it made the whole
movie
better it made like it just like the
the emotional relief i felt at the end
it was just like
ah you know what i mean
i was like whoa
that was dope so it's a great movie
i highly recommend it it's on netflix
it's called i care a lot
it's like a psychological crime drama
thriller
uh so make sure you check that out
now the next movie i want to review is i
saw on amazon it's called bliss and it's
with selma hayek
and owen wilson um and
these two are so good in this movie um
i have mixed reviews about the movie
but they were really good like she had
some really great like just grounded
real moments in this movie that i just
really enjoyed you know um
but anyway this movie is about wait let
me let me let me i want to just get to
the right thing
bliss bliss
film yeah because i want to read what
they say it's about
a unfulfilled man and a mysterious woman
believe they are living in a simulated
reality
but when their newfound bliss world
begins to bleed into the ugly world
they must decide what's real and where
the
where they truly belong now that's even
a different
description than the description that i
heard before
you know but some hack and almo all
wilson were really good in the movie so
again
it's sort of like an inception matrix
type thing
you know
you know where you know all you know a
movie opens and no one will
say sort of like sort of like weird
character
who like gets fired you know then he he
like accidentally kills his boss sort of
thing you think that's what happens
then he meets this some hyatt character
who has
seemingly has like sort of magic powers
she's like controlling matter and
you know making people move and you know
and so she's
trying to say to him that this isn't
real like she's like you're real but
nothing else is real
and so you're kind of going along with
the movie like oh okay
and then there's even a moment where you
something happens where they're taken
out of this
simulation you think but but then i
don't know if
if they really were was it like a
simulation upon a simulation are they
crazy
and this is my bad my critique of the
movie is that
i don't like when you don't explain
things i don't like when like later you
have to talk to somebody and be like
well what was that about and they're
like oh
well this you know well this was
actually
you know an analogy or you know a satire
to
you know i don't like all that [ __ ] that
artsy fartsy stuff
you know it's like were they in a
simulation or not
and to me they did not explain it
enough if you watch the movie you'll see
what i'm talking about
it drags a little bit it's a little
melodramatic
but i do think that their relationship
their performance
in the relationship was actually really
great
and worth watching so you know
check that out um bliss
on amazon but it really was
just i didn't know at the end was like
you know was it like were they in the
matrix or not
you know you don't really you know like
one of them's supposed to escape
they never show it you know what i mean
like you don't know
is it whether this guy's just like a
drug addict on the streets who's like
troubled and his family's trying to help
him out
because there's a family element i mean
i'm being vague about it because i don't
want to like ruin it too much
but like i would like for people to
watch this movie and then hit me up in
the comments
on instagram just to be like yo
maybe you get it maybe you'll be like oh
no this was great and the movie was
this this this and this you know that
would be great if that's the case well
man cue me in but if not
i don't know man just
[Laughter]
i just i just do not know that [ __ ] was
bizarre movie so bliss on amazon check
that out
last one though is uh you know uh the
wand division
ended and i really loved it i loved how
they wrapped up one division
i love that it was this whole this like
you know eight episodes or whatever how
many episodes of like you know
really delving into like wanda's you
know
origin story and then you just see the
end and then you know so then it's like
you know the real magic and then she
became the scarlet witch
and you know that's like all in the
marvel lore
and and all that stuff and so i thought
that they really wrapped that up good
and there's all these little easter eggs
that you know hopefully they like i hope
they keep doing this
like like when netflix was doing the uh
the other you know whatever that other
one was with like
iron fist and and uh you know those
it was good but it wasn't the mcu
so it was made like a tell it like a law
and order television it was made like a
television show
and some of it was like real cheesy and
all that kind of stuff you know
um you know with luke luke cage
a daredevil daredevil i thought was the
best one and the punisher
like the way they made it it was grimy
but it didn't feel like it was a part of
the mcu
so even though there were parts on one
division that were very cheesy and corny
it like but i felt like oh well this is
tv
but there's still a part of it that's
like makes me feel like oh this is still
part of that avengers universe and we're
learning more about it and
it doesn't have to go away so i like
that
this series has that and i hope that the
other series
the falcon and the soldier and and all
the other series i hope they're all
like the universes are connected in in
this way
and then you know we can keep the
stories going so i
really did you know enjoy that let me
see where i'm at
all right where am i at here guys like
49 minutes
i think that's good i think we're good
um
anyways guys i want to thank you for
you know listening every week you know
i'm i'm trying to figure all this out
i'm
i actually am talking to a couple of
people about being
you know coming to be my intern and
really helping me with all this
so much response from to my fighter and
the kid
about website help so so many people are
hitting me up so i'm narrowing that down
so we're gonna get a new website and i'm
gonna have somebody come in and help me
so we can make more clips i can make
more content i can do stuff more stuff
with my patreon
i could just do more stuff more content
to put out there for you
and the people that are fans and i
really appreciate those fans so
and again watch me i play i'm on every
day on twitch
doing call of duty and avengers and fifa
and i'm gonna start playing 2k
because like because i have the the game
pass and it's free
so we'll play that for as long as that's
free so i'm gonna check that out too so
but listen you know riffing with griffin
man we're starting a new era right now
2021 the world's coming back so you know
i'm i'm booking stuff for the road
i'm i'm gonna get out there again so i
might be coming to a city near you so
once my new website gets going you'll
see my dates and stuff like that on
there so make sure you guys look out for
that
and you know and wish me luck you know
when you watch this if you're listening
to it in the morning
keep your fingers crossed send out some
good vibes from me that i booked this
job
you know but if i don't it is what it is
but i love the thrill of being like in
the mix
and so it's like you know if i had to
give
you guys advice out there that are in
the entertainment business and
you know how do you deal with this and
you know i don't mind getting super
excited about stuff
as long as you can manage your
disappointment because that's what it's
really all about
it's okay to be like you know it's like
people you know you don't want to be
like one of these people that doesn't
get thrilled about things
you know what i mean because the
business is like that it's like you get
an audition in the mail you do the
audition and you get great feedback and
then the feedback is like well the
producers want you to do this and you're
like what
and then you get excited about that and
you're like the network and the studio
and
you get all this excitement and your
managers and agents and you have to sign
a contract and you
having just having excitement about that
kind of stuff is totally okay
but just if you get let down you have to
be able to like ah
damn it didn't get that one
deal with the the pain deal with the
hurt deal with the disappointment
and then move on and then that's what
you have to keep doing
because that's the only way to survive
the entertainment business because it's
a lot of know y'all
a lot of no it's mostly no and you
sometimes you get
a really great yes so
keep that in mind next week i'll be back
with
um real world advice from a grown-ass
man you know
thanks again to our sponsor uh better
help
betterhelp.com and you know go get your
10 discount at betterhelp.com
and thanks again for being here and i
will see you
next week
you